i like that we're rgb i like that we're
rgbs
nicely this is fun yeah
troy's gonna show up and ruin it no
matter what happens the whole thing up
yeah
what could he be to make rgb work he
could be like he could be white solid
black flame we've got enough whites
solid black
yeah we were before you
literally did that joke before we
started recording yeah
well it was a i feel like it was a
collaborative joke because we were
talking about how we
collectively were the american flag
because we're red white and blue nice
very good you like that look at us go
excellent work anyway hi everyone have
you been
i forgot how to do this show what do we
talk about what happened it's only been
two weeks but it feels like it's been a
month
it really does putting a first time
traveling internationally since the
pandemic in the middle makes everything
from before that trip feel like oh that
was back during the pandemic and
pre-paid
i got this taste of normal life yeah and
so it feels like
you know anything from before that is
now that earlier it's like the previous
chapter of my life
100 so you get that from being in
brighton 100 just going to a conference
and like oh yeah you went to a
conference having dinners it was weird
was it unsettling at all
um like were you
i was i definitely forgot how people
work
definitely like i'm definitely like yeah
you know i have to be kind of very
conscious with my communication
generally just because i i have lots of
challenges with that but
i genuinely forgot like how to talk to
more than a couple of people at once
so like i was i found myself like you
know we do that once a week here it's
different it's different on a screen in
a webcam like like i've had i've had
friends over but only ever like in very
small groups and you know whatever or
were they strict one person at a time
talking rule but like
no but like
sitting outside with like you know
three or four kind of uh people from the
same industry kind of chatting and just
having to remind myself like to look
inclusively at the other people i'm
having eye contact problems pretty bad
doing eye contact is something i'm
having to like relearn yeah so wait what
does that mean that you would fixate on
one person naturally because you're just
like yeah if i'm speaking if this is if
the three of us are stood in real life
and i'm talking and i'm like
specifically talking to you austin about
like i'm asking you a question about
something you do or like directed
specifically at you i had to remind
myself that like alana's also there and
like it's rude just talk directly to you
and i need to like look around the group
like i was having to like consciously do
eye contact with i'm having an issue of
not looking at anyone
really just struggling to like maintain
eye contact i feel like it's a weird
thing to do that i'm like what do i need
to look you in the baseball that's
strange that that seems a bit much
i barely know you're funny yeah it's
weird exactly it's definitely
we saw each other not that long ago and
i didn't get any feeling of that from
you should have because we spent most of
that time walking meaning there was no
way for us to look at each other direct
movement forward yeah you didn't notice
that i was i was doing this
you're a crab walking the whole way i
was staring and then highly i never
broke i never even blinked no i didn't
notice it sounds like europe
i know austin's the alpha of this
podcast that was such an alpha ha ha
take that troy
um troy thought he was alpha
i'm sure
what's what's the one up from outside
apparently what's the one of like the
john wick kind of lives outside the
system what do they call that
is it's sierra no
wait a minute
is what i think it is too am i supposed
to take advan offense at acknowledging
troy as more stylish than me um that
it's like i i would i would think if you
did that you've been kidding yourself
for a really long time yeah i mean
that's like yeah
okay i just wanted to make sure you're
very stylish your assortment of hoodies
and shirts serves you well as someone
who only wears hoodies and shirts
mike also
we understand we can't play i don't even
i don't even [ __ ] have to troy baker
cat
yeah i i don't even uh
i don't even have i have like five
shirts that have actual stuff on the
shirt
i phased that out at some point it's all
just single color i don't know i don't
like a logo shirt anymore i mean this
one is um this is a santa monica studio
gay pride shirt
thus i love it but
uh i phased those out a while back too i
have very few logos anymore it's like it
it's it's a weird thing i don't i don't
it wasn't intentional or just aging yeah
i think that's just the thing that as
you get older you're like less graphic
tee graphic tee to me is like very early
20s kind of i love them in my early 20s
and when i was a teenager all about i
will banned tv in your defense your
early 20s was like six seconds ago
that is technically true you could argue
that that was three years ago but it's
been a long three years austin it's true
you spent you spent two thirds of that
uh alone in this tiny pocket get sick
yeah yeah
we went through the twenties but yeah
how was your how was your trip austin
how was it your international adventure
i actually
all the i had all the same questions you
were asking mike of like is this going
to feel a little weird i mean i've been
to a few concerts you know not just that
bowl but been to the bowl a few times
been a few other things a few times you
know i've hung out had a few kind of
small dinners and been to restaurants a
few times but they're all very mitigated
you know like the restaurants at least
in la the policy is
a very kind of in my opinion nonsensical
you know you have to wear a mask as you
move around but as soon as it is down
you're apparently in like yeah you're in
a pathogen-free zone now uh and so you
know it feels a little ceremonial to me
more than but you get used to it and
whatever
on the contrary uh the trip
uh felt
literally like going back in time
because
i had to do a lot of hoops to go you
know had to have proof of negative
vaccination i mean of of complete
vaccination and proof of negative
test like pcr
test
and they checked it at every stage like
i had a layover
at the newark airport in new jersey and
they checked my stuff again despite
having checked it at the terminal at lax
and then on arrival
in
belgium and landing in brussels
uh i've always wanted to go there oh it
was awesome it's beautiful once having
made it through the
membrane as it were
it was like okay
now
you know we rely on you that if you feel
sick you'll tell someone and you'll
isolate yourself yeah that's that's
that's the condition and so and of
course right now you're in nicaragua as
is required to return to the u.s
right oh that's we all have the same
experience right yes yes yes that wasn't
just you i promise
yeah i am i mean when you know this is a
screenshot kerry's just had to spend two
weeks in canada for that exactly oh for
visa stuff to get into america i tried
to go to canada but the stupid consulate
was closed
yeah no thank god didn't have that
although did uh have to go through all
those hoops again and for some reason
the test that was arranged for me by the
hotel the day before my flight
i think i misread i got an email that
had a barcode i thought okay i'm good
they just they see the barcode they
click the thing it's done um apparently
that they were looking for like a pdf
print off of their results computer that
says you are negative because i showed
up at the airport at five in the morning
having been drinking up until i went to
the airport so i was on precisely zero
sleep and
sitting at the airport
um
and they're like yeah this isn't
uh i don't know what this bar code i
don't have never seen this before and i
was like but
all i've done is what
people who seemingly more in the know
told me to do at no point did i kind of
go rogue and try to figure this out on
my own
and they were like i don't know what to
tell you but we have a little kind of
pop-up operation and so it's quite
freezing at five in the morning in
belgium in october and so uh had to go
stand outside and go through a little
bit of a comedy of errors scanning they
wouldn't there's no physical anything
it's a qr code and of course the signal
was was was crap so i had to
like you know take a qr code and then
copy paste the link email go back into
the airport email it to myself use my
laptop to get on the wi-fi then fill out
the form for my appointment go back out
there get the like pay
uh it actually was very reasonable i
think it was 50 euro for like a
20-minute turnaround test to finally be
told it's just all well and good except
for the fact that
45 minutes earlier was when we had left
the bar and it was
now like 5 30 in the morning and so it's
just like the head space of going oh man
this is so i really thought i was just
going to come to the airport
just kind of relax go through and then
you know but otherwise yeah i make it
sound dramatic it was all not a big deal
we were able to hang with friends
go to a bar it all felt there were no ma
i didn't wear a mask the whole week uh
and that's the first time that that's
been the case
basically i said australia was like it
was like i kept feeling weird leaving
the house without one but i was like oh
i don't need one here though
yeah it's true yeah their attitude there
is you definitely still need one in the
uk
same here
yeah i think the uk is actually doing
worse right now unfortunately um we are
yeah i think we're doing quite badly by
what metric like um absolute numbers or
a per capita
cases
yeah
more of everything well i mean well so
in terms of ratio i think the ratio is
similar of like
you know cases to admissions but we have
a lot of cases and therefore a lot of
admissions
um the hospitals are starting to stack
up a little bit again which is a bit
worrying going into winter
yeah i don't know where your mask in the
bloody shop british people watching this
said that in such a british way where
you're masking a bloody shot well yeah
yeah yeah
what are your [ __ ] mask so we have
got the apple repairs put a mask on
oh i wonder what the cockney rhyming
slang for mask is
i'll just say up front there's got to be
one there is there are groups that
define these there must be london is
doing much worse than l.a
yeah much worse
like 30 000 to a thousand like london's
30 000 new cases we are 900.
yeah wow
very very stupid i i think yeah you're
doing much better with the kind of i
think british people
to an extent have quote unquote gotten
over this and are are being very silly
they've just gotten to a point like bit
much in it
it's a bit much it's trying to go to the
public
i wanna you know where's my my my blitz
spirit my freedom um yeah it's it's a
lot of that nonsense and it's a shame
but it's um yeah it's everybody
yeah
saying
got some family members with kobe at the
moment so i i know people who have
covered in london right now too actually
yeah um
but
we could get into it but i was like yeah
i don't wanna i was gonna report on how
they're doing but i was like i'll leave
that to medical professionals than my
anecdotes ah master baker hello
this is solid already this is where are
you what typically clean shavings
you can't record your audio can you
no i could be here for like two minutes
we're i'm at dinner with the team
where are you in the world right now
troy i am uh i'm in uxbridge
oh you're in the uk right now i forgot
you're
we were just talking before about how
stylish you are just as a heads up you
should know we are in fact recording in
case the team you're with is a thing
that should not be recorded as part of
this he didn't say who they were you
just said to the team i know i know
that's why i'm trying to get out in
front of it there's a thousand oh
yes bridge it's fine there's a million
games he goes for juice
you look great
well we were just talking about travel
how is it how do you feel is it nice
being overseas
um i will say this there's a lot of
hoops you have to jump through in order
to
travel now which is good i think there
should be a lot of hoops um it's easily
manageable once you figure it out but
then you get here and it's like never
mind
it's like okay
um
and clearly i'm in a restaurant right
now
no mask and it feels like the uk has
kind of
gotten themselves under control a little
bit
that is definitely not true
[Laughter]
oh that was a terrible troy where troy
when you're out the restaurant put
mascot please i don't you get sick
no no no the the beauty of it is that
the the production that we're on has has
taken incredible precautions for us oh
that's cool
everyone is you know you're alone and
that's right what's the cool things
about yeah but the cool thing about
flying austin you know this because you
just got back is that
they're like everyone has to say that
they're they don't have kobit before you
get on a plane
and so then you get on the plane you're
like i guess we're good
but man the second somebody coughs
you're
like yeah
you still have to wear they they really
aggressively enforced the mask on the
plane like if you fell asleep and it
like falls down they're like they grab
you and they're like put it on that
happened to me
uh i got yelled at to put my moss back
on while i was drinking she was like you
need to have a mask on and i was like
i'm drinking
what
hey can we have a conversation about
physics they're like you're not a
scientist
i think i would not have been able to
resist just telling him okay you know
this is on you and then just absolutely
make a horrible scene do an airplane ago
yeah exactly yeah
demonstrate the drinking problem
i do miss you people and i just watched
the morbius trailer and i wanted to talk
i want to talk all about it well my
intention for this episode is to talk
about dune have you seen it troy
so it's been really great
being able to see you guys
i've not seen
ipad not my ipod
[Laughter]
watch it like this does anybody have an
ipod anymore i downloaded it on my ipad
and the only thing that
is keeping me from watching it is people
going you didn't watch it on your ipad
did you yeah i mean honestly dude it's
it's
it's definitely the feedback is right
yeah that's not a movie to watch that
way uh
it is a rare it is a rare film that
that it feels so
uh
like grand in its spectacle that
it really is yeah i was pretty blown
away by it uh me too all right
well and i know that it was one of the
reasons about can we talk about chris
pratt being everything and and the irony
of me saying that i was gonna say like
all the people to tweet on that subject
troy i was
but that's the thing is i'm the one
that's saying it is like look i get what
i'm saying
but wait i thought it i saw that there
was an announcement that he's in a new
um
i'm already playing it was
i think the anime
don't check
my feet as much these days and so i when
i saw it it was for you you don't check
your feet as much
my feet i stare at longingly all day
long yeah exactly
no i uh
i uh
uh no no i i i yeah by the time i
checked in on that it was like we we'd
well gone past the initial reaction and
we were in meme territory and i was like
i don't know what this is and i don't
care but but it's still isn't that just
mean garfield and mario then like is it
fair is there more than the two no it's
just that those two are unexpected like
they're iconic characters that in my
head i would not go
oh chris pratt have we thought about him
this is this is the same problem this is
this is why i can't read about this it's
because people go you're in every game
and i go do me a favor
and
tell me every game that came out this
year
and tell me if i'm in it or not
also the thing is
uh
[Music]
no games have come out this year it
doesn't count no games have come out
this year troy
no games have come out i'm sure you're
in ratchet and clank somewhere
somewhere deathly
i love the kind of bragging i'm not in
death loop yeah i think he's funny but
he's not bitter about it he's not upset
about it at all
i love chris pratt and definitely though
that was awesome
he plays the black lead in death
no but i i it's it's the same thing as
chris pratt i mean you get the you get
the back to back you get the the
bioshock and the last of us back to back
and people are like oh he's in
everything now or tom holland same thing
he does the three-point land and the
uncharted trailer people goes oh i see
spider-man it's like
well
no i agree you're at a lot of games
you're in a lot of games
also in your defense like you're in
literally a spider-man game and an
uncharted game just use your last
example
you know the funny thing is i didn't
even know that troy was in miles morales
until i was playing it and i was like me
too me
and then he's like neither oh this
[ __ ] again i had that one time i
left the podcast to go play the crew
for fun house and so i had heard troy
and then i was like is that [ __ ] troy
he's inescapable i've started imagining
him in roles that he's not playing i've
started no i've started being like is
that troy and it's not it's chris pratt
that's the level it's chris from which
are three i'm like that's nice
relative to the uh uncharted is to
spider-man
criticism that i get i don't know that i
share that uh i also know that
i don't know that i really even care
enough to
to kind of get worked up over it to me
it seemed fine but but um but if
acknowledging that
um
the the in your defense like
rarely are
is that the thing it's like if people
don't even realize it's like how many
people this is obviously a slightly more
esoteric example but like how many
people played medium or pathless
and then as the credits rolled went what
the [ __ ] really uh when they saw your
name so that's the big difference i
would say not to hopefully to
stick and move in these days man because
i don't want people thinking that
look i learned a lot from the example of
nolan north and it wasn't that
you know
nolan north necessarily was in every
game it was that nathan drake was in
every game like
people looked at that they were like
that's what we we want a relatable
affable charming wisecracking guy
that character got cast to that point i
really gotta point out the fact
rahul kohli who is probably the number
one
guest on the show friend of the show um
he's the most frequently recurring guest
on this show i think yeah
paul gray he tweeted us something today
and he said you know
this tweet didn't age well and he was
talking about you know how he wanted to
he doesn't want to take roles away from
dev patel
but he wanted to take roles you know
from because i want to go up to the
roles that are being offered to chris um
chris pratt and chris hemsworth and
chris um
whoever the other crystals are
christopher guest
i i have not looked at that in such a
succinct clear cogent way
and i was like this this tweet is still
you know it still stands out as um
solid content
because that that is the truth and i i
fear
that
representation is not the end of the
conversation when it comes to diversity
yeah this
this music right now is not underscoring
my point well at all
yeah
i think a lot of people can say that
well as long as we have diversity then
or representation that we have now
been diverse and i don't think that's it
i think that it's it has to go further
up the river and that if we just end
with representation by saying look we
have someone we have a person of color
we have someone who is lgbtq plus we
have someone then therefore we are
diverse as opposed to going are you
rethinking the way that characters are
being created and presented and then it
doesn't start with casting it starts
with the writing it starts with the
production
so
i don't know i just i really i i give
bad props to rahul for helping me be
able to frame that conversation in a
much better way as opposed to going
oh here's here's another role that you
could go out for that's yeah
it's like don't just give me the brown
dude he got a lot of tweets like i think
he quote tweeted a few of them when
squid game came out where people were
like you should have played this guy in
squid game
just because he was brown
yeah that's it
that's why that's uh there's i missed it
i assume him not being able to speak
korean no it didn't matter
you should have you should have been the
brown one what be honest with you i've
been guilty of the same thing pakistani
guy yeah like like yeah which is
especially hilarious uh in rose i was
guilty of that though i thought it was
like man there's a dude on this show
that looks like a friend of mine and you
that should have been you is like why
because he's a black dude
and i'm like man i've got to change the
way that i think about this it's like
instead of it being that
why couldn't it be you were the um
you were the main white dude you'd be
literally any of them yeah literally any
of them
um i don't know it was
it was it was a cool
i thought that that [ __ ] like bob also i
know we talked about it quite a bit but
i but to that point of
i felt like they did a really good job
at making it only matter
to a point um
the kind of the like the
the brownness as it were and the
religious like the muslimness it
mattered in in a few crucial areas but
the majority of what that character
did uh the sheriff of the game
oh no sure party of the character of the
sheriff in midnight mass is like it was
totally non-contingent on any of that
like
all the terrible stuff was just his
humanness
nobody casts as sheriff as a brown dude
nobody does that that takes somebody
thinking
oh i should get rid of this default
image of a white dude being the sheriff
in my mind like that takes a
creative to think that way to make that
one my favorite
my favorite uh
i'm not usually a big fan of the kind of
trolling quote tweets i just kind of
scroll past it but i did laugh when
somebody uh
said you know would have been better if
they cast a muslim instead of a hindu or
something and he was like atheist
pretty hard at that i was like all right
that's nice that's that's uh because
they also just assumed he was hindu
based on his last name which is like a
whole separate
well exactly that's the thing like
there's a lot that kind of gets revealed
in in that exchange that just and his
handling of it was was pretty deft i
thought it was pretty funny
um but um
in any case i food just got here so yeah
which chain you in troy which chain is
that i'm trying to work out it does look
like a chain it's a chain i can't i tell
you anything
oh it's a it's um it's one of the up
market burger places so i'm guessing
is it honest burger no
which one mcdonald's
beefy
right now guys it's not a good situation
for me
it's not the most appealing name
you show us can you show us your meal
it's will be the judge of your meal no
it's just it's i i had i had guilt for
the side of shame is what i had
smothered in disappointment so that's
what i'm gonna effort that's that's some
fries for sure
oh yeah um well enjoy yourself thank you
for joining us
enjoy all the oxbridge has to offer
um yeah the chris pratt thing was is
interesting because i feel like it seems
like people are disproportionately uh
upset about it because actually the
reality is just that it's funny like it
is just a series of memes which makes
the conversation or the discourse seem a
lot more potent than it actually is but
it's mostly just
it was that he was so unexpected as
mario that nobody especially because um
the original voice sector what's his
name uh charles martinez is actually in
the movie as well you're like wait a
minute we're gonna have some weird cameo
for him or something i think they have
several flashbacks he said he's in he
plays several characters
but chris pratt is mario which i can
actually see it working it's odd but i
can see it
like do you think with his he's going to
just do chris pratt like he's going to
mario yes
for garfield he can't but garfield i
feel like he's got to do something
different garfield's got to be a bit
grouchier than your regular marvel movie
hero chris pratt it's true i'm intrigued
yeah there's a very heavy lethargic
quality to the default state of a
garfield character that i don't think i
can picture ever once
in any role of he tends to be such
energetic rules like just by virtue of
the character
yeah interesting agreed
um
but it is it is interesting to hear troy
talk about the perception of being in
everything i've never thought about how
he feels on the receiving end of
everyone saying that all that joke yeah
i've definitely made that joke myself
several times as well yeah i feel a bit
bad not do it and like i never even
really thought about it
but he
he's very good at what he does
well i you know and we've talked before
um like he and i have talked not on the
show i mean but about
um we have conversations outside the
show what the hell occasionally by
mistake you know we've been having
separate conversations without him when
he discovered i was actually a bag
checker
you know how he is he has to have a 10
minute conversation with the checker so
we ended up talking and gives you a gift
yeah yeah um so yeah we uh
said um
he was saying how you know in some ways
his fantasy is to kind of go uncredited
and just see if anybody can figure it
out because the goal is to disappear the
goal is not to be such and such game
featuring ex-actor the goal is to
reinvent and that i relate to i remember
the medium i wouldn't have known it was
him
i think a lot of things like i i like i
i take the piss but like he's got
incredible range i wouldn't say this if
he was in the room he's an incredibly
versatile actor he doesn't sound like a
joke for that reason
no it's true the yeah the the the
character
like booker dewitt is a lot closer to
his
normal speaking voice but still it's
still got some affect to it that's
different you know like i don't think
joel and troy would get along i don't
they're so different
as people that i don't even think they
can have a conversation i think so too i
think he'd hate him yeah but troy
wouldn't hate
one side troy would desperately want to
be i don't think troy hates anyone by
default i think he likes
yeah he'd want to impress him you're
right he would really want to impress
him he'd be like it's really important
to be the children start speaking in an
accent to him while they were having
conversations to break him down he'd
want to impress him by playing guitar
playing guitar yeah but then joel would
think it was pretentious
like versatility
you don't have it
i think joel would mainly just be like
having a nap because he was in a safe
modern world without zombies that's true
he'd be pretty chill but like i think
versatility often we like the assumption
of that is that troy would definitely
not have survived the zombie written
version of reality yeah that's
impressive
all comes to our world yeah in the in
these
sony's just turns into a roast as soon
as troy leaves we complimented him we've
only complimented him but but i will say
like versatility genuinely especially
and this is very true in troy's case
like
versatility doesn't mean you're
unrecognizable in my opinion that's not
because you've got you've got of
specific vocal chords you've got
specific it's not about how much makeup
you can put on your face or how much you
can sound different it's about how much
you can inhabit genuinely the
characteristics of different characters
and a lot of the animation sounds
they sound like themselves but they're
playing different people and yes troy
has emotional range
i can i can trust him in a lot of
different roles a lot of different ages
a lot of different like backgrounds of
character tones of tones of performance
as well like he's got great comedy chops
but he's also chris pratt
i've seen less of that
so far right but how much of a fun plot
twist would it be if he absolutely
killed both roles i don't i actually
don't doubt that he's capable of it like
that's the thing that always comes up
with these casting conversations uh
austin you mentioned uncharted earlier
like that's a recurring thing is like
the people who are making these choices
have reasons that they are doing it they
know why they are doing it you know like
it's like whenever there's like a comic
book character who's bald and the same
five names are just thrown around
twitter for like that's why we're bad at
costing and there are professionals who
do that and i think it's weird to not
give people the benefit of the doubt
when it's like do you know what they had
to go through to get there and how many
people they had to prove themselves to
doesn't mean it's like one-to-one like
the the criticism about tom holland is
he's in a really tough spot i think like
watching the uncharted trailer
definitely it's it as a film
isn't hugely appealing to me um i was
like this is a lot of different stuff
that i'm like oh i like that they've
meshed all the games together like
that's kind of exciting um
obviously meaning it's not canon
tom holland's in a really tough spot
where
we see him as being so young because
when we were introduced to him he was
really young he's now 25.
and there i've seen so many comments
where people say
he's too young to play nathan drake and
i want to be like nathan drake was a 25
year old at some point was he never
allowed to be 25 but our experience of
him he's 29 i think
when you first meet an uncharted one oh
i thought i could be wrong ten more ten
years older than that i i was 29 going
on 40 though as a character wasn't he i
could be wrong it might have been older
um i i don't number yeah well i your
judgment is or your guess is probably
more informed than mine but in my memory
he was always
you know he was 31.
an uncharted one
i like it it looks fun to me i i think
as well but honestly i think i'm just
getting old most young actors look young
to me now i can't
yeah but it's also like he's introduced
to us as spider-man like and and as a
high school kid right like playing a
young character as well yeah it's not
like i think he's like
still no part of me looks at him and
goes nathan drake and i'm always okay
with that i when i was a teenager and
the first iron man movie was coming out
i was such a little snobby piece of [ __ ]
about it that i was like he doesn't even
look like tony stark because i thought
that i was cool because i read comic
books and that this film was like you
execs don't know what you're doing and
i'm very glad i've gotten past that era
of my life my my attitude now is that
they also thoroughly proved you wrong on
that one
definitely proved me wrong on that one i
was so convinced it was and i like i
cared that his eyes weren't blue like
why did i [ __ ] like the james bond
conversation that happens every single
time i to the extent now that i'm pretty
sure the james bond pr team trigger it
intentionally just to get it in the
conversation the heath ledger is such a
change
like that we thought that it wasn't
right you know like it's just i don't
care anymore if things that's probably
the best just no point like that's
probably the same
that that is probably the most like
actor win moment ever because i don't
think there was one person that was like
heath ledger absolutely and then and
then similarly afterward not one person
that was like okay well that was
anything short of
divine revelation totally and it yeah
it's didn't it kind of also happen with
um phoenix with joko i remember lots of
people being sniffy about that or you've
got on what's his name in 89 batman
phoenix i i had no doubt that he'd be
able to do that because yeah he he never
has an actor yeah he's oh i'm an
incredible actor and i feel like heath
ledger also kind of it's like that seal
was broken and you know and never mind
being the same character but just even
the
the like the novelty of an actor
making such a heart about face yeah i
mean he was just too pretty was the
thing that was why everybody doubted him
was like this hot guy no how dare you
associate it also with very fluffy roles
you know like yeah you know not the most
substantive things i hate about you kind
of yeah like fun i mean i guess i guess
i guess i take that back in the form of
um
um what's the uh angley brokeback
mountain
um true
um
but
that's not theatrical in the way that
the joker is uh it's so introspective
yeah that i somehow yeah
seems like a smaller leap yeah i agree
but it's not but credit where it's due
on that one yeah exactly yeah exactly
but it's it's just yeah whenever this
stuff comes out
you know i i don't know that i felt like
i i feel super compelled to go see that
uncharted movie based on what i saw and
it is hard to make those connections of
those characters being the characters
that we know were so familiar with
nathan drake but
my attitude is they don't have to be the
same or i would just play the games
again like they're allowed to do
something different
they have to i feel like if i go see
that movie i'd want to see a reason why
it was made into a film like it'd be
like what is the why when these games
are so awesome
um why do that but i don't feel like are
the same they are very film-like yeah
um
but like the chris pratt thing is it's
mostly funny i never would have expected
that guy to play mario in
a million years
but that doesn't mean i don't think he
can do it
how funny would it be if it turns out he
has no lines it's just literally just
the whole time right he can't do an
italian american accent he can't
probably know it's pretty good that was
pretty here we go
i think my peach is better hang on oh no
[Laughter]
why why are they even hiring yeah yeah
yeah some yoshi's as well
yoshi i can do some yoshi oh you sorry
are you upset because i didn't say yoshi
yeah yeah we say yoshi in australia
well you're where are you actually kind
of insensitive of you to question her on
that austin that is the uh traditional
australian pronunciation
but what [ __ ] country are you in
right now but where are you right now on
the red white and blue podcast thank you
very much i represent uh literally
australia's national colors are greed
and gold
[Music]
well this is a little piece of rebellion
yep sure is that's me rebelling
desperately trying to stay here on my
visa please give me a green card i'm
applying right now and it's expensive
thank you it's right behind you a lot
you can [ __ ] off the green card is
coming from inside the house
uh um so i have to say just
so no if you were gonna pivot uh go
ahead go ahead i was gonna make an
addendum to the whole um
you know actors who kind of are not
recognizable in a new role because this
is definitely there's a whole composer
equivalent to that as well where there's
some composers that are very reliably
basically the same every time and then
there's some that go out of their way
to try to be maximally versatile and i
do
like i remember once there was an
interview with danny elfman where he
said the greatest compliment he can ever
get is if somebody watches a movie and
they're shocked that they discover like
they're hearing the music and then at
the end they see his name in the credits
and they go holy [ __ ] really because i
think he became very self-aware and even
self-conscious
about the idea that he all the tim
burton movies created and like the
themed the simpsons that created this
idea of like there's a kind of danny
elfman schtick
yeah um you know kind of a kind of wacky
slightly silly
you know sort to play the simpsons theme
tune on your piano
the fact that he doesn't even have to
look
in fairness i just like i like i like to
celebrate austin's but it's backwards so
it's a little had to
not yet i uh how does the theme tune to
james bond go austin
sorry i gotta try to get my e
okay you got that that's right
very good
very good thank you
the whole thing
yeah and you got to do the mirror
[Music]
nice very good
very good um i was gonna say
i really enjoyed it i really liked it a
lot i've heard it's great yeah i keep
hearing people be like surprised too
they go and see it like expecting to be
fun and they're like like moved and
things like i myself spoiled it for me
oh i was so glad i didn't get any
spoiler i only saw it this weekend and i
was like i'm amazed
oh i saw the james bond film oh do you
like it yeah i liked it oh you know and
then said the obvious spoiler that
everybody's amazing you would expect her
to say to me uh i i really i was moved
by it too i thought it was fantastic i
feel like i need to go see it again
because i feel like i've tricked myself
and i thought it was so good that i was
like this is a [ __ ] phenomenal movie
but i'm like confused but my point was
gonna be
it feels like han zimmer plagiarized
himself
like some of the
for about some of the music you're like
that's just a dark night you just took
the dark knight it's the same thing and
it sounds so so so similar that i almost
was
caught waiting for another note to come
in that's
in the exact order but there's just one
note missing from the dark knight
so similar i think part of the reason
for that is
um
hans was a replacement to another
composer who was oh i didn't know that
uh oh okay and it could be that by the
time they reached that point it was like
let's we don't want to we we've
it bit us in the ass to kind of do
something unusual because the guy they
hired a really talented dude named dan
romer
i don't have any clue the circumstances
of his firing i felt horrible for him
because this was like a massive step up
in in in
like uh visibility of
film he was pr before that famous for
like like the one that put him on the
map was like beast of the southern wild
and um
uh and then he worked on um
he did have a pretty big hit uh around
the same time his bond earlier with the
pixar film luca
but he was attached to bond
like two years ago
um
people from from our neck of the woods
would know him as the composer of far
cry uh five the the the like cult one
and he did an excellent job it was one
of those funny because i i um i pitched
for that job and i remember when i heard
his score i was like well that's
basically everything i wanted to do but
i think he probably did it better than i
was gonna so like well done i
they chose well ubisoft uh and um so
yeah he is nothing but my
respect and admiration and and um
and uh and so the idea of like a huge
blockbuster action film was wildly
despite the far cry credit because the
music in far cry is not like that it's
not a big orchestral thing
i i remember being really intrigued that
they were willing to embrace on on a
franchise that has such an iconic
musical fingerprint like there are
there are
i could improvise in the style of bond
like like it's a vocabulary so
established that composers have to adapt
to it it it it was interesting john
berry created a sound john berry did
like 14 bond films in a row
and created this sound that's sort of
like
part very melodramatic orchestral part
big band jazz you know part like the
electric guitar it's almost a little
like fusion um
and um and never mind the fact that
people also forget that the bond themes
is like a steady parade of some of the
most
lusciously romantic music imaginable
like you forget that those scores all
the sort of love themes over the years
are some of the most saccharine and just
like expressive and beautiful themes
very sexy music which is not a qualifier
i use for music very often it always
happens to me sexy is like
like to me it feels more earnest it
feels like legitimately as if it is this
is the sound of
of
pure like souls meeting like pure true
love which is hilarious because that not
once does a bond film i mean the most
recent ones kind of flirt a little bit
with the idea of him actually sort of
getting vulnerable and then and then you
know horrible things happening and then
like
they did that a little bit in the
timothy dalton
uh license
famously is the is the bond who married
right like that's the yeah and timothy
dalton's going to fall out of that
well because the i think license to kill
the very opening is the
the wedding
that they get like attacked and she gets
killed like or whatever at the wedding
and so the whole movie is he goes rogue
for revenge
um and they try to take away his license
to kill and he doesn't care
um and um i mean it's been taken away
like 30 times yeah exactly it didn't
never takes it's just kind of a song and
it's a game they play yeah it's cute um
but yeah to me it was always so
so funny that like the the just the fact
that it works the formula somehow
actually uh sort of they would have
these incredibly romantic music with a
guy that's
pretty overtly like a misogynistic
like woman predator who just doesn't
seem to emotionally engage at all and
the music is just so ignorant to that
fact and portraying it like it's this
almost mythological love story yeah and
so yeah it's so sad i could see when
they hired dan romer you know stepping
into that there's a certain expectation
even a composer like thomas newman who's
very much got a sound when he stepped in
to do the um the ones like skyfall and
spectre that that were directed by you
know this the the guy he works with a
lot um
um the hell's his name the guy that's
married to kate winslet um um
oh
i'm blanking on the director's name he
they they've done a bunch of movies
together uh
ah that's annoying me
this is annoying me i got it please sam
mendes thank you oh uh sam mendes
position
like like thomas newman and sam and just
have a long running history so he
brought him into the fold of those bond
films and you can hear
the moments where he's putting on the
bond costume and then the moments where
he's being a little bit more
thomas newman of himself um and it's
great i mean it works awesomely and
skyfall was the first james bond score
nominated for an oscar i think the
second ever wow they're generally
overlooked despite being some of the
most iconic
music of all cinema history
but um
in any case uh yeah i think that the
idea that the hans zimmer
you know kind of didn't reinvent the
wheel
on top of that you know not to hans gets
a lot of criticism for the fact that he
has built up a team around himself so
that if he's you know
as life is very busy and he's working on
a lot of projects you know people will
help make sure things get to the finish
line and while i don't know the internal
division of labor
too precisely i do know that dune was a
deeply
passionate and personal project for him
it was basically his dream you know he
told the director danny vale new like
this is basically my favorite book of
all time i've longed for an opportunity
to work on some worthy like some
adaptation that's like
does the books justice you're clearly
doing i feel like the dark knight to me
like that that was not at all what a
movie i loved it
so did i
made it
i decided i had to read the book before
it so i'm like
quarter of the way through book one and
i'm just trying to get yeah it's what
it's worth the movie only gets about
that i've been told i've been told yeah
sorry i'm just trying to beat where the
book i'm trying as long as i can read
past the point the movie is i can watch
the movie that's the rule i've set
myself because i want to read yeah it's
um there aren't really any spoilers
anyway because as someone who's not read
the book
it very much does feel like literally a
chapter one in any of the fantasy novels
that i've ever read it doesn't even feel
like book one it feels like oh you've
this is literally just the introductory
chapter um but
both visually and auditorially i don't
know if it's a word
just incredible like
just just so pleasant to experience
so many beautiful shots the one thing
that i keep thinking that i could have
done without
was just a lot of slow-mo where there's
some woman going
because they're in the desert
maybe a little bit too much of that for
my liking but otherwise i was like it's
just a feast it's fantastic it's so rich
and like there are all the cheesy words
i can throw in there it's luscious it's
visceral it's just i want to see it
again it's in imax like i started in
imax once and i'm like i want to do that
again maybe two more times because i had
such a oh wow a good time just absorbing
it even if the plot
didn't mean that much to me
yeah i think i'll miss it in cinemas
unfortunately because i'm not doing
cinemas yet but
i will get to it at some point for sure
that uh
denis valeneuv is such a beast of a
director i remember blade runner's
phenomenal beautiful film
i never saw his very first he did a film
his very first film before prisoners
i've never seen but i remember when i
saw prisoners did you ever see that with
hugh jackman and terence
oh my god really i did yeah
but then to go from that to sicario
where that was like amazing
[ __ ] hell that movie was gripping it
just like that guy can master an
atmosphere
like so few other he always feels like
he's really in control like he
everything is planned it wasn't one of
those like ah [ __ ] well just we gotta
we're running out of daylight get what
you can get like a lot of movies it's so
hard to make a movie especially you know
even with a huge budget there's still
just so much to get done and there's so
much ambition that they always feel like
they kind of just barely
work and it's like it's like really
lucky when they really come together
because it's so hard a producer friend
of mine once said no movies ever made
they're they're they're forced by sheer
will into existence uh like it it is it
is such a daunting task and games are
really no different yeah
it's so it's so and as you've talked
about mike repeatedly like under the
hood the the duct tape and wd-40 that is
the reality of most of it movies are
often the same you know like all the
sets and props and everything it breaks
the instantly yell cut because it was
not meant to last more three seconds and
it's just you know it's really really
hard to make and yet
the really great like the
transcendentally great directors feel
like somehow they managed to
outsmart all of that and every shot it's
like they got exactly what they needed
and they knew what it was going to be
before they ever set foot on and his
movies like a rival jesus christ what a
like that might be one of my favorite
movies that [ __ ] what a what a film
beautiful very [ __ ] and and i think the
thing that like
when we list any of these movies and
that i have not seen prisoners but other
than that
um it it really is pacing like i feel
like
they're all just so
perfectly paced like
blade runs consistently
layout is slow
yeah and it felt slow it felt a little
like there's a difference between slow
from a pacing standpoint and slow from a
i'm starting to believe my own [ __ ]
about myself and like i'm indulging and
like i thought it was incredible but i
also only watched it once which is
generally telling oh it's good second
time definitely go back
it well for me the thing i think the
thing that i it suffered for on the
first viewing for me was and to be
honest this was true of the original
blade runner for me as well was i wanted
to see where it was going so i was
constantly annoyed at it for not telling
me what the plot where the plot was
going and i think both both blade
runners definitely benefit from
re-watching when you know what's going
to happen you know where it's all going
and you can just kind of
the lack of a better phrase live there
for a bit you know i mean just enjoy
that world and that ambience it's what
you're saying the kind of atmosphere of
it and the sense of place i think that's
probably a really good assessment as to
why it felt tedious to me uh because it
is such a wonderfully conceived
plot
world like there's such good
storytelling that you do want to see
where it goes that it's a little
difficult to take the pedal off the gas
and enjoy the experiential aspects
i think modern cinema has trained us to
be kind of plot
two plot too much care too much about
plot in our especially in like sci-fi in
action movies like
this happens then this happens then this
happens then twist then twist and this
happens like we're we're kind of there's
a rhythm that's now expected well
actually there's probably a little bit
too much what
it's just it's we we and i think in in
sacrifice of tone and world building and
character stuff like i think we've been
oh i definitely agree with that there
are some people who are total absence of
character in the interest of plot which
is the the opposite of
every university lecture i ever had
about writing just don't just have
interesting characters people can be
complicated the plot can be you need to
go to the bank today
like that and i think
part of that is that's what all
audiences remember plot like and i think
talk about plot more than they talk
about characters it's more marketable
but what's more marketable it's more you
can tell people there's spoilers and
then that makes them rush the cinema
it's just interesting i i shared a
conversation last week with a very
talented game developer making a very
cool game
and we got to the subject of story and
the story he pitched me for his game was
all
lore that happened before the game
started it was kind of all of the kind
of the the the set up basically and this
is what my world is before the player
starts
and having to kind of and i just
basically gave paul bastard i gave him
like a bibliography of books on writing
to buy but but it's like it's that thing
of like that's how we consume stories
now i think to an extent it's i when i'm
going to the cinema to watch like an ad
like the fact that when i saw there was
a dune movie and that people liked it my
first thought was oh i have to go and
read the book so i go in knowing what
it's you know what what this is about
and everything or like when you're going
to a comic book movie and you watch at
least i do the youtube video that's like
here's every 10 things you need to know
about this character you know so you can
sit in the audience and go ah that
costume is from comic number 93. you
feel smart
yeah it's a weird it's and that's
probably not the best way to consume
stories or think about stories and as a
writer i have to kind of push myself
away from that all the time towards like
character arc and world building i think
you've done a pretty good job of that
mike i think you've done a pretty good
job of that well i'm you know right
you know it's funny though i i do have
to go
oh well then i have nothing funny to say
you can give me a real just i'll give
you 60 seconds austin and then you don't
feel nervous i had it pretty quickly
uh with someone earlier today we were
talking about exactly the kind of pitch
that you just described mike where
somebody goes into great depth i've had
it happen where i'm being onboarded to a
project and they say you know they give
me this huge really exciting description
of their world but then and then it's
like
yeah and they're like oh well the game
is you use smash bugs uh it's a
platformer yeah and it's like it always
feels so heartbreaking to realize that
they've they've put so much energy into
the environment sometimes the money
people want that as well but i will also
say
it's fun
for the writers those writers rooms
where you're like and then this and
because that person did that those days
are so exciting
it's super fun to do and it's fun to
tell everybody else and for you all to
get excited about together so it's like
it's the most exciting part it's more
exciting than
what is their arc
i don't know i don't know
i filled my my wall currently it's just
all post-it notes for my next game just
working out all the mapping out all the
arcs and i love that that's my yeah to
me that's threading the needles of how
can i see i also like arcs but i tend to
interact intersect them with plot very
heavily too and not just be like and
then wisdom occurred like they're always
in some way related to key events and oh
yeah they should yeah plot should drive
character and characters should drive
plot like at all times yeah it's a yeah
when you said that people remember plot
more than characters that like it's
interesting i don't know if that's true
for me because when i think of like the
first thing that came to mind when you
said that was this is a slight spoiler
on how to train your dragon two but
unexpected but okay
these are movies full of big spectacles
who scored how to bring your dragon to
john powell you're actually right
that is a [ __ ] good example of me
remembering the dynamic between the
characters and not the it's when it's
when it's when his father and his mother
reunite and there's this standoff and
then he just goes and hugs her and it
was like oh what a moment it was so
beautiful so
and like it totally
didn't expect to end on this note but
thank you for watching please listen
everybody i'm olympia that's mike bethel
that's austin wintry we'll see you guys
next week bye